the probability it's defined as the
number of successes divided by the total
possible outcomes
okay so probability just in basic terms
it's what you want
okay the chance of something occurring
that you do want divided by the total
possible things that could happen right
and that's called the theoretical
theoretical probability okay
whereas odds you're comparing favorable
outcomes to unfavorable or in the way I
would like to say it is what you want to
what you don't want okay so let's look
at some examples and we'll compare so
say for example here you have a hat
there's three red marbles two blue
marbles and one black marble in the Hat
we want to find out what's the
probability that you're blindfolded you
reach in and you pick a red marble well
according to our definition there's
three chances of getting a red marble
right so the probability would be three
divided by the total number of outcomes
which is six and you can reduce that
down to one half so that's the
probability okay you can also write this
as 0.5 so probability is in between zero
and one zero means no chance one means a
hundred percent guaranteed okay now
let's do a different example say we want
to know the odds that you pick a red
marble well there's three favorable
outcomes three things that you want okay
compared to three things that you don't
want unfavorable so the odds would be
I'll just write odds it's three to three
which is one to one you could also write
this using a colon one to one okay or
you can even use it right with a word to
one to one odds okay so that's one
example let's look at the spinner over
here okay say for example the spinner
we're going to spin it and we say well
what's the probability that I land on
two well there's only one two okay these
regions are all you know the same size
and shape so there's one chance of
landing on two divided by four possible
outcomes the probability is going to be
1/4 but if we said what are the odds
that you land on
- well one chance of landing on two -
three chances of not landing on - the
odds would be one two three
okay now let's switch it up a little bit
let's say we want to find out what are
the odds against landing on the number
two so now the odds against means we
don't want to land on two so what are
the chances that we don't land on two
well there's 3 9 2 s 2 1 2 so the odds
against would be 3 - 1 notice it's the
reciprocal of the one that we did odds
in favor so odds in favor is what you
want - what you don't want odds against
is what you don't want - what you do
want
okay now experimental versus theoretical
probability what's the difference well
say for example we run an experiment
right we spin this spinner 100 times and
out of those hundred times let's say the
number 2 comes up 22 times okay so the
experimental probability would be 22 out
of a hundred trials that's the
probability and you could reduce it down
it would reduce down to 11 50s right you
can divide them both by two but what's
the theoretical in theory what's the
probability that we land on - well one
chance of landing on two out of four
possible things that could occur right
so experimental you just think you're
running an experiment you're running
trials you know you do it a hundred
times or 20 times or a thousand times
and you count how many successes how
many things occur that you're interested
in having happen out of the total trials
and that's your experimental probability
now as the number of trials go up okay
assuming that this is you know balanced
it's these are equally spaced the
spinner you know there's nothing no
glitchyness to it and whatnot this
experimental probability will likely
become closer and closer to the
theoretical probability but who knows
maybe there's some other factors that
are influencing you know the
probabilities in such a way that they're
not the same okay but these are the
definitions so probability odds odds and
favor eyes against experimental
probability and theoretical probability
so if you're enjoying
these videos you're learning something
as I hope you are subscribe to the
channel
I leave me a comment and I look forward
to seeing you in the next video